so i have an infinite series here the
sum from n equals zero to infinity of
negative one to the n power times x to
the sixth n over two n the whole two n
factorial and my goal in this video is
to evaluate this this power series when
x is equal to the cube root of pi over
two
and i encourage you to pause this video
and give it a go on your own and i will
give you a hint the key to this is to
figure out well what function is this
the power series for and then use that
function to evaluate this and there's
another clue here is that hey this this
is kind of a mysterious or suspicious
looking number here pi over two that
looks like something i would use a a
trig function to evaluate that that
might be a little bit more
straightforward so i'll let you have a
go at it
so i'm assuming you have tried so let's
try to work through this together and
any of these types of
problems i like to at least expand out
this power series so i get a better
sense of what it what it's like so this
right over here if i were to expand it
out this is going to be equal to when n
is 0 this is 1 actually this all of
these are 1 so it's just going to be 1.
when n is 1 it's going to be negative 1
x to the 6th
x to the 6th over 2 factorial when n is
it's going to be positive negative 1
squared is positive 1
times x to the 12th over 4 factorial and
then let's just do one more when x is
equal to 3 it's going to be negative x
to the 18th
x to the 18th
over
over 6 factorial you just keep going on
and on forever
now off hand i don't know a function
especially a trigonometric function
because that was kind of our clue here
this pi over 2 makes me feel like i
might this might be a trigonometric
function right over here nothing jumps
out at me offhand but but this does look
suspiciously familiar this looks awfully
close to the power series or the
maclaurin series for cosine of x which
we have seen multiple times let's just
remind ourselves what that is and if
this doesn't look familiar there the
previous video where i do the maclaurin
series for cosine of x goes into detail
on how i get this the maclaurin series
for cosine of x
is equal to so i'll just write a few
terms so i'll write approximately equal
to
1 minus x squared over 2 factorial
plus
x to the fourth
plus x to the fourth over four factorial
minus x to the sixth
over six factorial and just like that
you're probably seeing the similarities
well the first term's the same the sign
negative positive negative positive
negative positive negative positive 2
factorial 4 factorial 6 factorial the
difference is the the powers the
exponents on the x's this is x squared
this is x to the 6. this is x to the 4th
that's x to the 12th it says x to the
6th that's x to the 18th
well what if we
what okay so some something for you to
think about is well how can we can we
replace x with something here because
anything that i change if i take cosine
of
if i change x i don't know a plus b
everywhere we see an x you would replace
it with an a plus b can we put a power
of x here so that these things end up
like that
well this x of 6 is the same thing x to
the sixth is the same thing as x to the
third
squared
that's x to the third squared this right
over here x to the twelfth is the same
thing as x to the third to the fourth
power
this right over here is the same thing
as x to the third
to the sixth power
so if we could replace each of these x's
with x to the thirds we will get this
power series up here well how do we do
that well we would just say well it's a
cosine of x to the third and actually
let me do that in a different color
so the cosine and that's not a different
color
so the cosine of x to the third
is going to be equal to
and once again every where we see an x
we replace it with x to the third so
it's 1 minus and actually i'm just going
to put in parenthesis squared 2
factorial which i want to do that in the
green let me do all this in the green
all right so it's going to be equal to 1
minus
parenthesis squared over 2 factorial
plus
parentheses to the fourth power over
four factorial minus parenthesis to the
sixth power over six factorial and now
let me get change back to that move
color and since i'm taking the cosine of
x to the third well this is going to be
x to the third
squared this is going to be x to the
third to the fourth power this is going
to be x to the third to the sixth power
which is exactly what i have right over
here
so this right over here is the power
series for cosine of x to the third so
evaluating this when x is equal to the
cube root of pi over 2 is the same thing
as evaluating this when x is equal to
the cube root of pi over 2. let me write
that down because this is interesting
so this
so i'll just rewrite it from n equals 0
to infinity
of negative 1 to the n
x to the 6th n
over 2 n
factorial
this is equal to this is the power
series representation of cosine
of x to the third power
so if you want to evaluate this when x
is a cube root of pi over 2 we just have
to evaluate this when x is a cube root
of pi over 2 and this does suspiciously
work out nicely because if you take the
cube of the cube root well good things
happen so the cosine
of
the cube root
of pi
over 2
to the third power well that's just the
same thing as cosine
of pi over 2 which of course is equal to
is equal to 0
and we are done